Today,
we are going to look at the three Cantos,
uh,
in the eight sphere of a dentist costumers who have beyond the planets beyond
the role.
This so called they'd sphere or the heaven of the fixed stars.
Before we get too,
which will be next week,
next time the Imperian,
uh,
the,
the heaven of,
uh,
of light and fire.
Uh,
and,
but now we are in the,
in the heaven on fixed stars.
And Dante discusses the three theological virtues and the three theological
virtues,
unlike the so called to distinguish them from the cardinal virtues that
Christians share with the classical tradition,
namely,
uh,
you know,
the,
the fortitude,
prudence,
et Cetera,
and justice,
et cetera.
The,
these are the virtues that deal with,
uh,
the understanding that the understanding of the divine.
They open up this a horizon of speculations about,
um,
about the language of God,
the God,
the way God speaks to us.
Theology in this sense,
the way in which we speak about God theology,
the logos in theology.
There's the word logos and a,
the way God speaks to us.
So it's,
it's,
uh,
it's the place of a in paradise where Dante,
we're focus on the meaning of what I call,
it's not my phrase,
basic words,
uh,
the words,
which are foundations of a,
the way in which we come out to discover who we are.
There words that we use,
the words that we may not even know exactly what they mean.
And yet the Dante,
we'll try to,
uh,
define them.
There are repeat faith,
hope and charity.
Um,
the three virtues,
uh,
that Dante,
we'll,
uh,
in this using a Paul's letter to the Hebrews where he accounts or gives a
deficiency at least of faith and hope.
But there are words that they are terms that always implicate each other.
You cannot go on explaining faith without really talking about hope.
You cannot go and talking about hope without explaining faith.
And both of them are recapitulated and come together,
gather within the question of a,
within the virtue of charity and the virtue of Love,
uh,
a virtue of love,
their words that they are very mysterious in many ways,
but they are,
but there are degrees of understanding all of them.
Um,
the three r examiners because don to go through,
uh,
the equivalent of a university examination and medieval bachelor's degree.
That's the term comes to us from universities,
medieval universities.
The bachelor,
Dante is a bachelor who presents himself to the teacher.
The teacher is testing him,
uh,
and uh,
he will,
uh,
who give an answer according to textbooks,
authentic where the authentic,
the deported of one's own beliefs,
once own hopes and one's own charity,
um,
are gathered.
The three teachers are going to be three apostles who are with,
uh,
with,
we're known as a,
uh,
Peter for faith Saint Peter for faith.
And that makes sense.
It was Peter himself.
The name stands for the,
uh,
the cornerstone on which the edifice of Christian belief,
is built.
The second one is going to be for the virtue of hope is going to be James known
also as the,
the Galician,
uh,
because why him,
to seem to be less obvious than the other two because he,
among of all the apostles is the one whose death was recorded in,
uh,
in the acts of the apostles.
And so he lived in a certain expectation of a life to come.
So he would seem to be the real figure of hopefulness of some idea of some way
of,
uh,
expecting,
a future,
a future.
And it retains a life of eternity.
The virtue of a chat,
it instead is,
uh,
is,
examined,
uh,
by John The apostle to distinguish him from the,
the,
uh,
this year,
the writer of the apocalypse.
So it's the three apostles,
Peter,
James and John are these other ways in which we could,
uh,
um,
we'll give some summary ways of,
uh,
trying to understand some of these virtues.
Uh,
uh,
one thing that I would ask you to look through when you have time to go in
detail of this,
of this texts.
It seems to me that all the three cantos deal or have as a kind of,
uh,
what I would call under text,
the sub subtext of them,
something that running through,
uh,
but,
um,
sometimes even visible,
but neural the time.
Visibles the question of exile.
Dante is retrieving the language of exile.
The Lang as if this virtues are clearly virtues that don't,
don't concern at all.
The Blessed in heaven,
decker only concern as here in time.
They have the,
the blessed in heaven certainly do not need a faith or hope or they don't want,
they don't really need to know about what love may be.
Either they have it or they will be there.
Right?
So this is,
but it's,
uh,
the language of a exile is running through these three issues just as the
language of time.
Uh,
so the connection between time and exiled probably needs not much explanation,
much glossing.
Uh,
we are in time,
we are fallen and it's only in the language of,
uh,
of the fall that it's possible to think about,
about anxiety.
The other,
the other,
um,
uh,
element running through this is really the question of a very visible,
especially in Canto 26,
the actual question of,
uh,
of language itself.
You know,
what is the language of God?
Um,
what are the names of God damn tasks?
Is that question do,
are we talking about,
uh,
an entity with a name?
And if so,
you know,
the whole debate about the so called a data Graham met or the four letters that
are supposedly the Taitra grab metal,
that name God,
that's what that word means.
The four letters,
uh,
day.
Are they known or is God just ineffable?
Is there some,
is it,
is,
it's some kind of reality we can know we're going to hope to May to name,
oh,
are we going to be related and connected to this idea,
this knowledge of God by analogical discourse is our positions,
uh,
the mystical position that denies even the,
the,
our knowledge of the name of God.
Uh,
the analogical position put forth by Aquinas,
for instance,
that we really talk about God and a logically and all the qualities we attribute
to God.
Uh,
only they're not real in,
but by what we may know in our own lives.
So Dante asked this question about where is the language or what are the names
of God and how do we get to know God's?
So the first,
um,
the first virtue then is the virtue of faith in many ways.
Literally say,
I call it a basic word because it's really a basic word because it founds us.
Uh,
it's a stone.
Peter Asks for the foundation of all this poetic edifice of the divine,
the divine comedy.
I would like you to think about this a,
the actual s me get into a text.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
this,
this actual apostrophe,
um,
or at the beginning of Canto 24 oh fellowship,
he elect to the great supper of the blessed lamb who feeds you so that your
desire is ever satisfied since by God's grace.
This man has foretastes of that which falls from your table before death.
Opponents is time,
give heed to,
is measurable,
is craving.
And we do him with some jobs.
You drink holders from the fountain once it comes and that on which his mind is
set he wants to know about.
But what I do,
what I would like to stress is the presence of this actual metaphor of a
banquet.
Uh,
it is as if Dante is a,
clearly we're dealing with a two metaphors here.
One which is exhibited,
the manna in the desert,
the falling of this.
Do on a,
on,
on the exiles,
the wonders,
uh,
the Jewish wonders in the desert.
And the other one is that the eschatological banquet,
but it,
this is,
this is as if any debate about faith has to be placed within a communal context.
This is not going to be the professional faith that where you may have it,
let's say in 1550,
roughly.
No,
uh,
the,
and I'm really alluding to as a contrast,
as a contrast,
um,
just to make you understand the case.
So,
uh,
the great debate between two fingers of the renaissance called Erasmus and
Luther,
they debated at length about the question of whether or not,
uh,
how a text of a written about essentially earlier and on 1440 texts by a
vanilla,
a great humanist or who wrote about the free world and the defense of their free
will and free will.
He,
they,
they were,
it was unclear to them what value really meant.
So they go on debating in Texas,
code on Threewill,
uh,
Erasmus maintains that val,
I really had defended the existence of freewill cause it's free will,
which is a gift of God.
Uh,
it's,
it's something that has been given to us.
And,
um,
uh,
the,
and therefore we really have to come to know God through the acknowledgement of
his authority.
But,
uh,
because the freedom that we are talking about,
he's talking about,
he thinks valley's talking about that actually comes from him.
And so,
but if free will we come to know and come to choose also the existence of
divinity.
Luther had a very radical ideas about the question of,
uh,
of,
of freedom.
Um,
uh,
there was no such a thing.
He would argue,
Eh,
uh,
ThreeWill.
Um,
and actually the world,
the universe is a universe of absolute faith and faith is freedom.
And it's given to us by freedom to say,
releases us from all obligations.
It frees us from more constraints.
It just makes us,
uh,
understand their own room.
Relationship to the Creator is,
uh,
without any other intermediary forces of the world.
So it's,
it's her radical theological claim of freedom and faith together.
It's very possible many people,
just to give you a,
to extend this argument,
there are many poets and thinkers who go on changing his and believe that for
instance,
freedom is actually the source of,
uh,
not faith,
but faithlessness that the idea of fate or once whole faithlessness may come,
denial of God may come from the assertion of oneself at the assertion of one's
own total freedom.
But this is,
I'm giving you this,
those two exemplify the nature of the debates and the force of the debates.
Dantian cysts removed the question of faith from one of radical subjectivity or
a radical faith.
Uh,
I aware that there may be some kinds of,
some,
uh,
a flip side to it that that faith and lack of faith really both depend.
If you reduce them to subjectivity,
uh,
one can go on sliding into,
one of the two options very easily.
Dante focuses on with this first image on the question of the communal
experience,
the banquet.
And that to me is part of the shared world.
Uh,
this,
this eschatological banquet where the All the vision where at the end of time,
uh,
but,
but the illusion is also to the manner,
uh,
where,
this,
this various figures are con the community comes together and then Dante goes on
really focusing on the individuality of the private professional faith.
It's really about him.
The interesting thing that I want to point out is that beer,
beer Beatrice's words to Peter and onlines 30,
she,
she goes on a appealing to him to go on to,
uh,
examining.
But she does so in a very peculiar way.
Let me read this passage and she lines three to all eternal light of the great
soul with whom our Lord left the keys.
There's no,
this is very canonical.
It's part of the Hagiography,
the,
the account of uh,
uh,
the no graphic representation of pita with the two keys which he brought down
all of this wondrous joy test.
This man on points,
light and grave is Aussies.
Good regarding the faith,
but which the workers on the sea,
it's an illusion recorded in the gospel of Peter Walking out of an act of faith,
walking on water.
Jesus asks him and tells him.
So the strange thing about this reference is that Peter did not want to walk on
water.
It is the moment of,
let me call it the crisis of faith.
The moment where Peter had no faith.
And in fact,
Jesus calls him all men of little faith.
Why don't you walk?
And then he,
uh,
I guess feeling that he's teetering on the,
on the brink of their base.
You can imagine a really see sewing over the waves finally does manage to go on.
This is a poignant moment because clearly Dante's emphasizing that there are
degrees of faith and that the so called crisis of faith,
uh,
must not be seen as denials of faith.
On the contrary,
that somehow there is a social dialectical movement between Eh,
professional faith and doubts about owning and,
and,
and the,
that's the,
the,
uh,
owning this,
this gift,
having this gift of faith.
So this is one of the strange moments,
edits in the light of this,
uh,
strange fluctuation between faith and an experience of not faith.
That I think that the are what happens later,
uh,
has to the way it has to be to be understood.
And then whether he loves rightly so rightly hopes and believes here the three,
you're the language of the three theological virtues or come together.
It's not hid from the,
since our sees them and so on.
And then Dante users,
both a,
uh,
the language of the university,
lie academic life as if this were really a,
an academic test.
We'll come back to this issue in a moment.
Uh,
justice,
the Bachelor,
oh,
that's,
that's the,
uh,
the bachelor of arts,
the Bacalao reactors as we call it,
armed himself.
So there are tool that is the weapon of knowledge,
the academic knowledge as a force.
Knowledge is a weapon just as the bachelor arms himself.
It does not speak to the master.
A McGeester submits the question for argument,
not for settlements.
And it was the issues,
uh,
issues that always need the open endedness over argumentation.
And not that of settling of a,
of the point.
I am myself with all my reasons what she was speaking to be ready for such a
questioning and for such a profession,
speak good Christian,
declare myself now this is that a knowledge that makes him,
that makes him visible,
declared herself but in orange that does not keep him hidden.
It's all two brings him into,
into existence,
makes him visible to us where his faith.
And that's the question,
uh,
that he,
that Peter Asks and the answer is may the grace which,
uh,
which grants it to me to make my confession to the chiefs and children I began
giving me right utterance for my thoughts.
And that went on as the truthful pen and illusion is to Paul a questioning a,
an authority.
And the word authority as you know,
is that which is what we mean by authentic.
And authorities are key keywords.
That word is Doritos.
I mean it's that comes which is worthy of faith.
Um,
the teacher is not necessarily worthy of faith.
You can question your opinions of the teacher and reject the question.
There's a distinction between the master and the author.
Uh,
the one or the authority,
the one who is an author is one who is worthy of belief,
where their faith.
So he quotes Paul.
So this is a canonical answer,
is the truthful pen of the dear brother Paul wrote of it with the father,
put Rome on the good path.
Faith is the substance and then literally the foundation that which lies under
or things that the ground of all things,
substance of things,
hope for us or faith.
You know,
if you went to understand faith and we ought to probably go and read about hope,
things hoped for and the evidence of things not seen.
And this I take to be,
it's quiddity quiddity,
a medieval,
medieval part of the medieval lexicon.
Meaning it's constitutive,
ah,
uh,
essence.
It's uh,
its specificity.
Now if you thought that,
um,
uh,
in the Middle Ages that won't go and talking about faith,
the famous formulation of faith comes from Tertullian who says,
I believe because it is absurd.
So that faith becomes the consequence of the extension of the absurdity of all
things.
And because they claim made on what one believes has in itself.
The idea of going,
being beyond reason observed in that sense of being beyond reason.
Uh,
and that's one of the ways in which faith is defined.
It really means that faith exceeds the realm of reason.
It means that faith can never really quite be an object of knowledge.
Dante does not pursue that line.
He tries to make faith and reason coextensive.
This is the sense of the,
I've got to qualify the term queer extensive and I will in a moment,
uh,
press officer.
They are not,
uh,
but they are,
they belong together.
This is the sense of the whole metaphorical pattern of
the university context.
So say you can know something about belief,
knowledge and faith really belonged to,
they implicate each other.
They are not the same thing.
Because if you really could know everything of what you believe,
then there is no reason why you should believe,
uh,
that which faith becomes necessary and necessity only because they are,
it's a way of acknowledging limitations of what one knows.
But linking knowledge and faith is not just simply a way of saying that reason
can know some of the content of what Dan believes,
that there is a reasonableness to what one believes.
That's all true to say that reason and faith go together.
There are certain claims about the reasonableness of what one believes it's,
but it really means,
I think at a deeper level that faith itself is a mode of knowledge.
That it is a mode of knowledge.
Exactly the way you have an orange of philosophy though it's modalities are
going to be different because philosophy,
uh,
submits to the rules of the rationality.
But fate opens your eyes and it's a way of showing you something about the world
that the reason alone cannot do.
So the binding of the two metaphors,
that's what I meant.
Coextensive but not identical.
It didn't mean that are identical.
The joining of philosophy and theology reason and faith made some projects faith
as a way of knowing.
Ah,
it,
it makes you see the world in different ways.
If then,
if you were trying to look at the world in the,
in the,
in the light of natural region and from,
and from their point of view of rationality.
So this is seems to be to be the argument and I set the terms,
uh,
against,
let's say a modern,
a subjective idea of freedom.
Freedom of faith is freedom that frees you from all.
And you're only,
I'm accountable to the creator,
uh,
or freed of faith as a mode of responding to the absurdity around oneself,
which is really the language of uh,
uh,
Tertullian.
And then this scholastic argument where that Aquinas of knowledge and faith
really needing,
uh,
to be,
to be together.
And then the examination goes on and I want to talk about 70,
uh,
then here doubt,
think is right or this is the beginning of the top of the page.
Can 24,
slide 68,
then I heard they'll think is rightly,
if don't understand this well,
where he placed it among the substances and after and after among the evidences.
And then,
uh,
and I then the deep things so richly manifest themselves to me.
Here are so hidden from men's size below that their existence lies in belief
alone.
Now it's a distinction.
This is Europe between belief and where we are.
The evidence of things not seen that paradox remain.
So there are things visible here in the heaven of the the fixed stars.
Uh,
no available to those of us were in time and uh,
in,
uh,
in the fallen world on which is based off the hope and therefore it takes the
character of substance.
If from this belief we must reason without seeing more.
Therefore it holds the character of evidence is a gloss on the medieval fill out
theological lexicon that Dante has been deploying.
Then I heard a four that is a pilot below for doctor,
whether that's understood there would be no room left for Sophos with,
and then this briefing from the kindle kindle love and it continued.
I want you to pay attention to this metaphor which we had,
well,
it me sitting around the table where I could ask you to speculate about the
presence of becoming a metaphor if for those acquired below four doctrine,
um,
I'm sorry.
Now the alloy and the weight of this money have been well examined.
But tell me if they're are hesitant in that purse,
all of a sudden the question of money and the question of faith.
Faith is literally
given as said,
it's said to be,
um,
money or do you have this,
this,
this Koan in,
in your purse.
I therefore I have indeed so bright and round that it's of it's mentored.
I am a no doubt.
Then there came from the depth of the light that was shining there,
this precious jewel.
That's one reason why the metaphor of money is used for clearly for faith.
It's a precious jewel on which every virtual rests when's did it come to the,
and the language is going to be,
it's from the printers,
rain of the Holy Spirit and the new parchments and so on.
But that metaphor of a money as faith,
uh,
really sort of has a way of lingering on in our minds what,
what,
what is the connection?
One connection or repeat is to indicate the preciousness of the faith.
One holes.
Uh,
it is,
it is really as rare maybe,
and this is valuable,
eh,
rare.
Uh,
beautiful jewels can be,
that's one thing.
Um,
but clearly there is more because the word money,
which Dante uses an Italian Monita same work,
uh,
it becomes a character in an English epic.
Monita comes from the Latin for Ma Mona Vale.
That word money as you know,
comes from,
uh,
it's like,
meaning a warning.
It's a,
it's a,
uh,
it's an advice,
it's a warning,
a warning about it's,
uh,
it's mintage.
It's,
it's,
it's part of the language of,
uh,
of,
we have the word admonishment that comes from it that monitors that.
It's an aura of it that it is really pure.
Okay.
So that's another way of referring to the purity of this faith that preciousness
before now the purity of his faith.
Uh,
the authenticity of it,
so to speak.
Uh,
and other Chait of money is that money has,
it's that which establishes the value.
It circulates,
first of all,
has the power of circulating.
Um,
that's an upset by the text,
but it's implied by the metaphor.
It is as if,
as if it is as if a faith has the power,
is that virtue that puts everything into motion and therefore questions and
establishes.
That's what makes it a basic word.
It establishes it's the substance or establishes the values of all the things
that are,
are around us but full of,
I cannot really get past my mind that Dante wants us to think about this kind of
the restaurants of profit nation there is in the language of money and link it
with really this purity of faith.
It is a safe,
there is the distinction is really never quite between profit nation and the
purity of faith and that somehow the world of faith comes out of the world of
nation,
that it belongs to the world of time.
It can be profane and yet it still manages to put things into situations.
The ambiguity of money.
Then beauty of the metaphor of money I think sheds a lot of light on this
virtual that Dante,
uh,
has been,
um,
uh,
examining a has been examined about it,
but he has been examining it for us.
Uh,
let me go and see how,
whether we can see more about this virtue by looking at the question of hope
that comes,
uh,
immediately after with the examination by Saint James,
I begin to tell you here just a little story that it's not an unusual story,
but as you probably know are the Greeks never thought of hope is a virtual,
um,
uh,
the,
there is a reference to hope in uh,
uh,
as being one of Pandora's being old,
one of the,
um,
the,
the entities available in Pandora's box.
You know,
about Pandora's box,
which was opened and all the evils of the world came out of Pandora's box.
Save for one.
Hope.
It's a statement.
It's a view that all is that really casts hope as clearly some kind of evil or a
delusion.
And in fact,
for the Greeks,
the idea of hope is always a,
a term that implies the delusion of exiles.
It's really what befalls an exile.
Someone who loses once,
once,
once land,
and what is left for him to do nothing but hope.
It's the radical illusion.
It's a kind of hope against all pack.
I have nothing more to do.
It's a self deception.
That's really what it is.
Dante does not follow that route for hope.
And in effect,
I think that he finds in the Bible the idea that Oh,
or,
or a kind of a new,
a different horizon [inaudible] for the,
the re thinking,
uh,
the way in which hope,
can be viewed hope first of all is literally a virtue of time.
More so a faith up with the language of the clock.
You must have noticed and Canto 24 introducing car,
uh,
that world of hope.
I did not want to talk about it because I know that we'll be talking about it
now.
Hope is as much of faith every virtue of time,
uh,
because it's a virtual Neroli of time.
It's a virtue specifically of the future.
It's tells me whenever,
if I have hope,
I really hope about the past.
It would be,
it would fly,
uh,
in,
against or sense.
There's no logic.
I hope we yesterday didn't rain.
That makes sense.
Does it read it?
But I can hope that tomorrow,
once,
no,
I can.
I can have that hope,
which would be a silly hope,
but it's a hope nonetheless because it's a virtue of time in the future.
It's a way of experiencing time in the future.
That's one thing that Dante's doing,
linking therefore hope and temporality,
but it's normally only virtue of time.
It's the most realistic of virtues.
Normally we think,
and the Greeks would sort of give us a cost to Paul's that you really hope it's
because you are really desperate.
You you hope because they have no rational reason or no realistic reason to
believe that things are going to go the way you wish that went for you.
So you go home and hoping dentist has no hope is the most realistic of virtues
because it tells me that nothing is really ever over.
That's what makes it realistic.
The the negation of hope.
The opposite of hope would be despair that you,
Dante,
you remember is the same for Dante is the thing that we find the encanto.
We never read it and now retrospectively I can tell you that you shouldn't go
and read it.
Canto eight of of inferno and even Canto nine.
The encounter with the Medusa is that fear of despair,
that idea of being petrified,
they may do's.
I can turn you into a stone.
There is to say that you are imprisoned and you remain caught either in your
standpoint,
all in that particular reality that you have all the idea of yourself as,
as as you like to.
As you think you have been in the idea of the past,
Dante says,
no hope is a virtue of the future.
It's a virtual that can even change the past.
In that sense,
it's affective.
In the past though it's the term because it tells us that the past may not be
what we thought it was.
You know,
whatever disaster you may have had,
whatever this appointment you may have had in the past,
that this appointment may contain seeds that really will reappear in the future
and maybe are preparing a future that will surprise you.
So this is a different understanding of time that Dante presents.
It's an understanding of time that once again down to the,
uh,
links with two moments of his,
which is sharp in that sense,
it's really not different from faith.
It fulfills faith.
It unveils the element of faith.
You can not really go on hoping about something like that unless you have some,
an act of faith.
Uh,
um,
and,
and 90 goes on explaining it in existential terms and,
and tying it to his own hope of returning to his homeland,
his own native city and the larger pattern of exile.
I want to examine that with you.
The poem begins with a,
uh,
with subjunctive,
the kind of 25 begins with an operative.
What do we call,
uh,
I wish,
you know,
oh,
that things were going that way.
Uh,
if,
if ever,
if ever come to pass
contingency,
there were these contingents in Italia uses a Latin is cause we don't really use
that in that sense.
But uh,
uh,
well I read it Italian,
even if Margaret who wish you were here,
uh,
semicon Tinga that's a lot.
Is if ever took a,
if I,
if everywhere contingent,
if it happened in that sense that the sacred point could point myself sacro he's
never come to pass at the sacred poem.
Don't usually sacred in that sacred means.
Remember that Dante uses the word sacred in orders in the double sense,
a sacred,
he's not investing it with some kind of a magic idolatrous power because for
Dante,
the sacred is never reduceable localizable if that's a verb,
a verb,
localize where in one object or in one particular place or he means it
ambiguously is that which contains a profane and the sacred within it hell and
heaven descriptions of Heaven and hell.
The sacred poem to which both heaven and earth have set their hand.
It's an incredible moment of prophetic self awareness.
I am writing,
but I know that without God I would not be able to be writing this poem that it
has made me lean for many years writing.
Now I'm sort of that I'm giving you this kind of a simple,
um,
a paraphrase of it.
The asco basis of writing,
writing as a pro.
You understand what I mean?
Writing as an ascetic labor of the soul,
it makes,
it makes me lean as if he were undergoing fasting the rituals,
the rituals of,
uh,
of,
of the,
the commitment to a particular labor.
So I call it the aesthetic labor of a,
of the soul.
Uh,
uh,
should overcome the cruelty that bothers me from the first sheep fold if I could
ever go back home.
But he called Back Home Florence and the candle hope cantaloupe or he's an
exile,
uh,
in the city is described in pastoral terms,
the metaphor of the city as a sheep for the pastoral language.
That language you expect to have in the backlogs of Virgil,
the pastoral tradition,
uh,
the idyllic world.
That's what we mean,
the pastoral tradition and way if it ever works,
some peas,
some idyllic,
uh,
ideally,
circumstances in that city.
And you can continue,
um,
where I slept.
This lamp here,
he continues with the pastoral length and then add me to the wolves that make
war on it with another voice now and other fleas,
I shall return the poet and the phone to my baptism.
Take the Laurel Crown for,
they're entered into the faith that makes soul known to God and after,
because of it,
Peter Does circle my brow,
so Dantes and still is in the,
in the,
in the circle of hope and the heaven of hope and yet now he's really thinking
about the last ceremony of Peter on him who blesses him three times as if it is
as if literally faith and hope are now converging the tool,
the two virtues come together.
What is Dante saying though here in this camp?
In this program at the beginning of this cancer,
his casting his hometown Florence in the pastoral language as a sheep fold and
then no,
he's alluding to messianic time where when,
if it were just when the piece were restored,
when the factions,
the wolves,
the wells,
you know the part of wolves and wealth,
it's very clear.
That's what etymologically the word wealth come from,
from wolves and the lambs will lie together almost a kind of impossible time and
messianic time.
When finally piece will be restored and he goes on adding that,
he would be acknowledged.
That's part of his hope.
He'll be acknowledged a,
there'll be a,
at that time who'd be acknowledged as a poet on the fount of his baptism,
which has,
you know,
you're refers to the baptistry of Saint John where we do have records that he
actually was Christen,
that's simple language,
but you have to ask yourselves why we'll Dante talk,
why would he use this particular metaphor?
The baptism is clear,
the place where a community is constituted and the baptismal font has that,
that value not only has that value,
it's actually the same baptismal font font to dump head.
You remember there had been a pro phonation of it in Canto described in Canton
19 of hair.
We're not.
This is that he broke one of those,
uh,
those,
those wells there,
one of those.
Well,
so exactly,
which we tried to understand in figurative terms since it would be inconceivable
that that would be capable of breaking it.
He says to him to rescue someone who's dying.
But what is a baptismal font for those of you who have no inkling of what it is,
is it's,
it's the,
what are we called the Sacramento.
The topological if you really are more textual and historical about about that.
A sacrament that that that ceremony reenactment of exodus when a child is
baptized,
he is literally said,
he's told actually that he is once again reenacting the crossing of exodus and
to me this is extraordinary.
The dentist says that he would be now acknowledged and be given the role of the
port on the baptismal font.
That question you have to ask yourself is,
and no doubt is Dante's asking,
how does a poet come home?
He imagines a trial at the baptismal font.
Is there the home,
what is the homecoming of poets that that's the hope and hope for the homecoming
where everybody will be at peace and there will be fair fees,
the festive mood and he was going to be welcomed back and he'll be hailed and
acknowledges supported rates,
fantasy of every the winners return.
That's literally what he say.
Yes.
He's using this language of a baptismal font,
which is the language of x averse.
It is as if you were saying that the poet can only come home in order to tell
his community.
That would have to get out again,
that all of them will have to do exactly what's happening to him.
That the exile that has been [inaudible] with which has been punished and wishes
before in him is really the message that his poetry can only give to the
community from which he has been exiled.
He's his con voguing the whole community around the baptismal font,
which is the figure of exile to tell them this is really where we belong in the,
in exile,
in the language of a spiritual exile and language in which clearly,
which could imply some kind of a re,
um,
remaking oh oneself,
rethinking on.
So now with this in mind,
Dante goes on seeing the,
and for whom below the visit,
Galicia an allusion to Santiago.
And then she herself will go on.
And I want to,
uh,
before we read the,
the,
the part,
the passage I went to,
uh,
give you this,
the Compassionate one line 50 Beatrice's presentation of Dante to Saint James
and that compassionate one who directed the feathers of my wings,
right of the soul,
the name of the family,
Ali yearly to saps sacks or higher flight,
anticipated my reply,
the church militant.
This is Beatrice has no the child more full of hope is this written in the son
that he radiates all the host therefore ease it granted him to come from Egypt
to Jerusalem.
That he may see it before his warfare is accomplished.
The other two points about which the disaster,
not for enlightenment,
for him to report how dear this virtuous today I leave to my himself for they
will not be hard for him nor occasion for boasting a and then like a pupil once
again taking this language of of school,
the school child,
the main thing about this person or this presentation,
but Beatrice is that Dante's journey is glossed through one figure,
one figure that have been telling you ever since we started this,
this,
this course,
this classes,
uh,
in September through the figure of exodus,
Dante's journey here is literally described as a journey from Egypt to
Jerusalem,
which is the master plot of the Hebrews exile from the bondage to the story of
freedom and exiled becomes really the,
that of exile is the figure of the master figure of,
uh,
of,
of the poem.
So Dante then therefore is linking now exile and hope.
And I think I already have indicated to you that this idea of writing is writing
their mode of exile is also that it's not to be seen in a,
in a subjective way only relating to him or the two,
the precondition for his own poetry,
but it involves the whole of history.
History has to be seen from the standpoint of uh,
of exile.
So they say,
Eh,
then,
uh,
there is uh,
Eh,
um,
pay at the top of page three,
63,
six,
align 69.
Hope I said,
uh,
again,
it's a sure expectation of future glory as the openness to time as futility.
And it springs from divine grace and precedent.
Marriage.
They're light comes to me from many stars,
but the three first is still that in my heart who will so sovereign,
single of the sovereign Lord David who told Dante is,
uh,
the greatest,
of poet.
Now.
Um,
so we move on from here now to the last,
the last virtual,
uh,
the last virtue of a,
of love.
Um,
the,
uh,
and,
and it is,
there is a progression,
faith,
hope and charity.
It is as if only you have to know this virtuous before the beatific vision can
even be possible to you.
You have to,
you have to understand what it is that they do to you and they produce in you.
We come to love however we are,
we would be looking for a definition of it as at least in a,
in a formula,
in a,
in,
in a kind of,
uh,
citation will formula a given and available in Canto 24 and 25.
We will be looking for it in vain.
There's no definition of love and it's clear,
uh,
to me it's clear to you,
I take that,
that Dante really thinks that this is the word,
the key word love is the keyword that seems to escape or possible finishers,
which we know around us in a variety of ways.
Uh,
we understand it and yet we cannot quite confine it and define it and that to
define it would really literally be a way of,
uh,
reducing its impact and reducing its,
its value.
It's such a basic word that Dante says that the only word that is really left,
he,
he is an imaginary at the Malo [inaudible] in this treatise on language that he
writes this treaties on the devil gather or he says that the word love is the
only residual term from the past.
That means that language is a way of like food.
The bank right at the beginning of Canto 24 is a way of gathering us and
bringing us together.
So love and food.
Food is given as a metaphor at the beginning.
Now love that escapes any particular definition.
And yet it's the culmination of all these theological virtues.
What Dante does,
C and a,
and he has,
I really want to,
uh,
turn to this scene,
at the end of Canto 26,
Dante meets Adam.
So it's the confrontation with the beginning is the competition with the arch
port because Adam is the one who named the world and therefore brings it into
existence.
That's really what we mean by poetry.
That's we're expecting of poets to do.
And since this is the meeting,
uh,
the encounter with him,
lines ninth and following Dante addresses all fruit though the,
the,
the word this is really is apple or apple or fruit.
That alone was brought forth,
right?
What on earth does he mean?
That's a strange way of addressing someone or all food that I was alone was
brought forth ripe.
There were a lot of theological debates,
uh,
as to,
um,
ripeness is an element of grace,
a description of grace for Dante.
Uh,
uh,
if you're not ripe when you're ripe,
when you have received,
they've been touched by grace.
So the argument was,
was Adam created in a natural state or was he already created in a state of
grace?
How long was he in the earthly paradise before he fell?
Could any fee if we feel it was,
um,
in the state of grace,
why could he,
why did he fall?
Uh,
if it was the state,
the reason why,
could he commit this sin of transgression?
Is it a transgression that he commits by eating of the fruit of the tree?
So Dante implies that he was in a state of grace,
right?
The first we miss right?
Plus the idea of,
uh,
of fruit.
That alone was brought forthright,
oh,
ancient father of whom every bride,
his daughter and daughter in law.
This is the very language that Dante,
we'll deploy in Paradiso 33 for the prayer to the Virgin and being the daughter
of her son.
Then the question of,
uh,
the divinity and humanity of Christ as humbly as I may beseech thee to speak
with me,
they'll see is my wish.
And to hear the sooner I do not tell it,
sometimes an animal,
let me just skip a few lines and see the answer that are Adam will give line one
15,
um,
and following no,
then my son,
that not the tasting of the tree in itself was the cause of so long exile.
So even Adam,
the fall was in a state of exile,
exile from the garden falling into the wilderness where he had to transform the
wilderness into the garden so that the work would be the way in which he could
regain that which she had lost the garden,
but solely the trespass beyond the mark.
I come back to this in the place from which the ladies and Virgil in limbo.
I longed for this assembly during 4,000,
302 revolutions of Sun.
He's clearly thinking about the handling of hell by Christ.
So that added now,
uh,
years two to the 4,000,
he counts in the Er.
And I saw it returned to all the lights on it's track 930 times what I lived on
earth.
The tongue I spoke was all extinct before Nimrod.
We saw him as the founder,
the giant.
It's a rescue over a Tom Mckee,
the classical idea of the giants fighting the gods.
Nimrod who builds a the tower of Babel.
So the,
the,
the debate between them,
uh,
hinges on language,
language is the key.
Now,
uh,
and retrospectively we really coming to understand the language of theology,
the question of what is the,
what are the properties of theological lines and what are the proper beyond that
of all words.
No,
that's,
that's the arguments,
Huh?
I spoke with [inaudible] before.
Not nimrods race gave their mind to the unaccomplishable task,
the building of the Tower of Babel that would not be finished for no product.
Whatever of reason,
uh,
since human choices renewed with a course of heaven can last forever.
It is a work of nature that main should speak,
but whether in this way or that nature of that,
but whether this way or that nature then leaves you to follow your own pleasure.
Before I descended to the anguish of hair,
the supreme good from whom comes,
the joy that swayed me was named I on Earth II in Italian,
not pie in the sense of you know,
the subject.
I don't think that that's what that term meant.
Uh,
and later he was called El Dante's using two Hebrew words where he takes him to
be,
he brought words for the name of God.
God was called e first and then he was called l.
In fact,
this is one of my students suggested to me that if you read them backwards,
they really spell out the word Ellie.
Uh,
which would be a word that we would acknowledge maybe nowadays as being the word
for an appeal to God.
He and he was called l and that is fitting for the usage of mortars is like a
leaf on a branch which goes on.
And another comes on the mountain that rises highest from the sea.
I lived pure than guilty from the first hour to that following the sixth when
the sun changes quit.
And that's the end of this encounter.
Let me focus on this question of a language that,
uh,
Dante's really with,
encounter with,
uh,
with uh,
Nimrod,
uh,
explicitly highlights,
Adam changes Dante through Adam is changing their account.
He had given in the devil.
God,
it'll Quinton's.
Yeah.
Which is a story about the origin of words and language and what did he had
claimed that the Hebrew persists the Adams language unchanged through history
because it was inconceivable.
He adds there that Jesus would be using a language other than that primal
language and not the corrupt language of human beings.
Now the story changes actually Adam's language hass has suffered the alterations
already in the garden where the names of God keep changing.
This I think is the key.
This is the whole question of theology.
Then their names all got God the way we speak about God.
God was called he and then he was cold air.
There is no proper name for God.
We only have words or languages that keep changing according to our own
historical circumstances.
And Dante goes on changing his own paradigmatic geomatic account about the
status of the sacred language.
He says there is no such a thing as a persistent sacred language in history.
What comes out is that language is the mark of our own distance from the divine
that we are in.
The language that we use is,
is a part of our own exilic circumstances and exhilarate predicament.
And therefore all the language of theology that Dantes is,
has been describing is part of this exhibit longing of human beings.
This is the story from 24,
25 and 26.
Dante uses theology in the examination of theology only to place us back on the
world or this world where we go on hoping,
believing a and loving,
uh,
realizing that these are all mysterious terms without which,
however,
that's another meaning of the word for,
of the resonance of money without which we,
uh,
where we know faith is a form of trust without which you cannot really be
functioning together.
Where we have hope as the realization of faith and where we have love as that
which is we are always longing for and somehow miss the meaning of which is
mysteriously escaping us.
These are the three fundamental issues that Dante is discussing.
And let me take some questions.
Yeah.
You passed over briefly this
statement of Adam that his transgression was in the,
not in the act of tasting the tree,
but in crossing a boundary.
Um,
I wonder if you could unpack that a little more because it seems to me not,
um,
it seems to me a bit of a controversial statement,
first of all,
because the command was you not eat from the tree.
So for Dante to say this,
it seems like he's,
there's something very specific that he's wants to get across in this of
boundary.
Um,
maybe if you could elucidate that point a little further.
The question is a question that I had really welcome and that was hoping someone
would ask the question is that,
uh,
I did not,
I read from,
I did not really explain,
uh,
the items statement when he says that he is seen was not in the tasting of the
tree but in the trespassing of the limit.
Let's say the mark.
Uh,
and therefore it seems that there's some issue of boundaries here and would I
our care to reply to give it a try to give a response to that?
Uh,
yeah,
I could give a response at a number of levels.
First of all,
um,
I would remind you all that this is Canto 26 or paradise and cancel 26 or
paradise is symmetrically connected with the other two.
Canter's 26,
uh,
the can't of Ulysses who also trespasses the boundaries,
who is a metaphysician of souls,
who,
who is dealing with,
with space,
uh,
and who himself there was really low or where on earth is his,
he's really going,
he doesn't know his destiny.
She was trying to go somewhere,
but that doesn't really know that.
Uh,
uh,
but they are connected.
Uh,
and then Ken took 26.
So purgatory dealing with,
uh,
with love,
in,
in it's,
it's,
it is pervert to the form of,
uh,
when entirely of the poets,
right.
And Cesar,
et Cetera.
So that's one of the connections and other connection is that listen at three
cantos where Dante's using foreign languages,
um,
they say deliberate connection.
They are there in Korea can't of,
uh,
of,
26 of in February.
You may remember that a virtual goes of the way to speak be the one who is the
interlocutor of Ulysses.
And supposedly they speak Greek in Canto 26 of purgatory.
Dante uses the province,
our language of our now Danielle,
who are now start speaking in,
in province are,
and then now we are using [inaudible] using their foreign language,
uh,
Hebrew,
the names of God.
So it's a,
that's one connection.
Uh,
so there are a lot of other of these connections in the case of,
uh,
of either who makes that distinction to come specifically to your point,
the WHO,
who makes the distinction between the tasting of the fruit.
And I was not a,
he tasted the fruit better than he trespassed the,
the mark that seems to be you right now.
It was a very,
uh,
controversial subject because indeed that was the,
the,
the command,
uh,
given to Adam,
thou shall not taste of the fruit of this tree.
Uh,
and,
and the presents Adam,
who instead that goes out to do that.
And it's clear that he thinks that the tasting of the tree was not he saying
there that was not his sin.
That's dentist take on it.
It's not the tasting of the tree.
There was the sin.
Uh,
the scene was that he,
uh,
abolished or boundaries.
I,
I read that,
I'm restating the Mercedes is changing slightly.
Sure.
I'm giving a paraphrase of what has been,
uh,
w w what seems to be,
the issue here.
It's,
it's clear that Dante things,
that Adam's act of eating of the tree was good and Adam's act of the eating of
the tree was actually the discovery of a knowledge that had but managed to
elevate him.
And that was good.
So in a sense,
from this point of view,
this is a,
this seems to be a contrast between Julissa's form of knowledge and Adam's form
of knowledge.
You list his form of knowledge is that he literally is,
does not go,
doesn't even know what he's going.
That's part of the problem in pure limit of physical terms.
You know,
he had no,
no directions.
It was a gratuitous quest.
In the case of Adam,
getting to know of the fruit of the tree was not an issue.
In fact,
Dante says that may be real knowledge is always going to be tied to an act of
making discoveries and making even transgressions what it was.
The problem is that they had been a loss of boundaries that he lost.
How are we to understand the loss of boundary?
It was the kind of knowledge that made Adam realize that he could be divine.
That was his problem,
but as soon as you,
the,
the imposition of the boundary,
God's imposition of or establishment of the boundary between the human and the
divine was also a way of letting Adam,
no,
I'm not going to read this as if we're a kind of [inaudible] statement at all.
It's all letting Adam know that he had to be aware that he was not divine,
that he was a human being.
What he Adam wanted to do was growing knowledge and discover that he could also
be divined.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
That is the issue for him to fall then would be a way of reestablishing that
boundary and realize that he is a human being and not divide.
So it's a growth,
it's a growth and self knowledge.
Well,
if you really know that you,
if you're here to know who you are,
you already have,
you have grown.
Do you see what I'm saying?
Dante's changing that sense of,
of what the fall of man is and the fall of man is not the fall in the growth of
knowledge,
but that growth of knowledge that leads you to you raising the boundary to
believe that you are by virtue of that knowledge that you have gained,
that you are now divine.
And just,
this is really what the whole poem is trying to convey to us is that this is a
stereotype amputation,
that human beings seem to have a,
and we kept,
we need to be reminded and when we hear it from God himself,
we don't quite believe it.
And then we have to grow into that recognition of boundaries between ourselves
and something that we aspire to,
but we are not yet.
Okay.
Good question.
But I had anticipated this answer must say,
uh,
in a number of ways.
Talking about Adam in the past,
I hope that you don't remember because more or less I said the same.
They got pulled.
I don't know that I mentioned before.
And you're one of my,
my one,
my one there.
Just to go back to the,
that one might wonder,
uh,
does Dante really make it clear that he's nearly,
not Adam,
but he's,
he's still things that he,
that he is,
he's Unisis at this point.
One thing that he understands that he is in the Canto before he acknowledges
King David as the,
the supreme,
and he did earlier,
the supreme poet,
he's really placing himself in David Psalms are the lyrical recapitulations of,
of,
of engrossing,
of exodus.
Uh,
that's really where he now I think is trying to move that he's more,
he,
he can not be like your races.
He knows he's not,
he does not want to be,
he cannot be Adam.
Uh,
that's the kind of model he's trying to regain for himself.
Okay.
Rush.
Maybe you see the connection with what we said earlier with what I,
they explore the response I gave to your question.
Yes.
He gets going off of Dante is theological beliefs in encounter 24,
he talks about his belief in the trinity.
Yes.
Um,
and I was,
what if you could just explain that further because he seems to be seeing both
at the trinity are three separate entities and the unity.
And I know there was controversy and different factions of different,
of different attractions and Christianity,
I believe different things about the trinity.
Um,
and so I was wondering what Dante believed.
Well,
uh,
Dan has a number of references throughout paradise to the trinity.
One of them actually have very significant one that we never talked about was in
Canto 25 of purgatory where Dante things that the way we human beings understand
the trick,
can understand that one of the ways which we understand the trinity is to,
uh,
to think about the,
the structure by my mind,
the memory intelligence.
And will we have the three by par to one thing and three functions or in Canto
24 total.
That professor Lumas I'm sure explained to you,
uh,
is that the,
if you want to understand,
Dante seems to imply when he,
he talks about I am one when he declares his own poetic a practice,
I'm one who wouldn't love a dictates inside me.
Uh,
go on using my languages on one wing,
which the trip there was explained,
they would say think about speaking to,
to make it make an existentially ah,
compelling and concrete.
When you speak,
you have an idea in your mind was it's babble.
You have an idea in your mind,
you emit a sound,
but to meet the sound,
you need the breath and you cannot have the sound without the breath and you
cannot have the sound without the idea.
So that speaking encompasses this threefold components.
One,
the truth is always connected to one.
Then in Canto 10 of a paradise.
You remember we spent some time there,
uh,
the having this idea of the love of the father and the son and the breadth of
love that joins them.
They get gone.
Gazing Twitter,
this idea of the fecundity or this idea of the trinity,
a source or Dante would things about God in the form of them,
of the mover.
Uh,
but he,
he,
he does go into that and yet he understands that that's not the affective
theology.
He wants to think of God as the prime mover to think as the,
the efficient cause it,
it,
it makes God is such a mechanic or a clock maker or something.
One of these images of,
of God who imparts all de and the recedes from creation.
That's really not Dante as idea.
He wants to think of,
of a divinity that is partaking of,
of,
of creations love,
uh,
Dante's idea of the tree.
So he has many,
many,
uh,
he tests all of these paradigms.
I don't think that he ever excludes one.
Uh,
he does not really agree with the reading of joking more Florida who thought
that the trinity was the unitive what could be dissolved into three separate
beings so that that's no longer the unity to have a humanity.
You've got to have all three are clearly present.
That's what Dante believes.
A unity with a kind of a,
is it a prismatic unity?
Let me call it,
does that by and saw the damn who would say,
we all have some recognition of the trinity,
whether it's uh,
you know,
God and the,
and the word of God being the Koran from eternally,
uh,
oh God.
And the word of God being car,
the Christ or et Cetera.
We all have the word made flesh.
We all have some kind of idea of the tendon where one or the knowledge of God is
a father or as a spirit,
ways in which we can understand,
uh,
this,
this thing we call,
I don't mean it reverently we call God.
It's a,
it's a,
so that's,
yeah,
that's the response.
Ask.
Please send an answer to the other question you were saying
all is good in some sense because it leads to more self knowledge and I
understand how it's different from Adam is different from Ulysses or that he is
trying to go somewhere like he's trying to become more like God.
And that's good because it's a definite end,
but it still seems that it's a means of trying to achieve that end is wrong.
Like if he's trying to become more like God,
fine,
like grasping instead of like we've been talking a lot about how the way off is
actually the way down,
not so essential.
And if he's choosing the wrong way to get to his end,
if that changes the end itself so that he's not even really,
you know,
Adam is not even like having the proper and in districts for notch either,
like it changes because he's going about it in the wrong way.
And just how that kind of reflects on whether the fall,
winter,
Dante,
thanks to the fall itself,
he was like,
good.
I was actually leading to cell phones.
No,
it's very clear.
The,
uh,
the question is,
the,
the earlier question,
I suppose it was about [inaudible] thinks of a trinity.
Uh,
and now the question is going back to other poet of,
uh,
Adam and my suggestion that the,
the,
the fall is good.
Uh,
and though,
because ultimately items seems to be wanting to reach God,
and I made a contrast to Ulysses,
and the limitation of Ulysses quest is that he's really does not know whether
he's driven by curiosity.
That's what I meant.
Um,
which we could talk about,
uh,
this,
evil curiosity.
Uh,
so,
but if,
uh,
if the movement toward the,
told the good is bad because after all,
Adam,
let's choose to trespass the boundaries.
Why should that really be thought as as good?
Is that?
It was,
that was the question.
Really.
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
the,
uh,
let me just restate this issue.
The problem with Adam with them sort of,
first of all,
with Ulysses,
I called it now the curiosity,
which as you know,
eventually we'll become good,
uh,
in the renaissance scientific curiosity.
Uh,
that's the good thing.
In fact,
I have a young colleague who is writing a thesis about curiosity book about
curiosity.
She has written a thesis about curiosity.
Linking it with,
uh,
a women's careers is a very interesting thesis to say that women are really
smarter than men because they've been attacked for being curious.
So she has found Renaissance Texas where some written by women who go on making
that kind of climb.
I think it's a great idea,
but how did dank understand curiosity?
How do the fathers of the church understand,
why is it bad?
Because that is the trait of Adam because curiosity has a particular quality
about it.
It's something that continues this whole understanding that there's a little
curious,
I'm going to give you well into the 18th century.
The curiosity is bad because he uses up,
you know,
curiosity has a salt of a restlessness.
Uh,
within it.
I am curious,
have a particular ability to observe it and I move on to something else.
I literally consume,
I use up in particular object and devaluate in that process.
That's really what made it so,
uh,
so bad.
Ulysses who goes from one thing to another and is always open,
fascinating figure of the renaissance spirit of discovery that,
uh,
but that's really what,
and does this,
this,
uh,
element homos of desire,
a kind of a figure of a in I on one to make using this,
uh,
to bad mouth a unisex,
but I figure of this way of thinking of the curiosity of your races is really
the don't Juwuan know who goes from one woman to another in an endless movement
of curiosity and knowledge that he's driven by knowledge to get to know certain
particular,
uh,
situations and uh,
and people,
Adam,
to go back to the question about Adam,
I'm only giving you Dantas reading Dante's reading.
He distinguishes very carefully between the testing,
the tasting of the fruit and the trespassing of the mark that,
that just passing with a mark meant you cannot really violate the boundaries
that I want to place between you and myself.
Because once you get to know yourself for what you are,
you may get to know me.
That's what the part of the violation of boundaries,
you may get to know me for what I am.
So it's,
it's,
it's a wall that protects both the essence of the divinity and the specific
quality of the human that is,
uh,
is at stake.
Um,
he,
uh,
Adam eats,
which means that he wants to grow in knowledge and Dante says,
that's not the issue.
That was not a problem with that.
I want to grow in knowledge.
The consequence of that growth in knowledge was the trespassing actually very
well be the cause,
the trespassing of the boundary head.
He really grown.
That's really a,
an acceptable aim.
You have to grow in knowledge and willing to say about Adam.
Exactly the things that you may recall,
I said about the sin of pride in when we discussed the cantaloupe 10,
11,
and 12.
It's good that you have this love of excellence and love of the,
of the growth of your own mind.
The consequence of it or the,
uh,
the,
the flip side of this quest for more knowledge is the violation of boundaries.
And that has to be reestablished.
The fall of man is only every establishment of a boundaries.
It's Nori way of mortifying the quest for knowledge.
Okay.
I'm restating what different terms of slightly different terms,
what I said before,
but I think that's really crucial distinction and I would ask you to try to
think that I see a difference between the two.
Uh,
the two situations.
I hope you will too.
I'll have time for another.
No,
we don't.
Okay.
See you next time.